Deadline to apply for the Cultural Bonus in 2006 shares this video
with the whole world of 2006 because I'm sure he is interested in it.
Pedro has already confirmed that the Cultural Bonus returns in 2004,
so if you were born in 2006 you will be given €400,
such as film concerts €100 for physical products such as magazines,
books,
video games and €100 for digital content.
Many of you are asking me the deadline for applying has not been specified
but I will tell you what happened in previous years for both 2 004 and 2 005.
The deadline opened in the summer and it was not until
September that they began reviewing the applications.
It also makes sense because it is when some cultural
losers of 2 005 expire I will let you know and I will
make you a step by step tutorial so you can order it.
So you know remember to follow me to find out more news like this one.